- C'était devenu une relique
oubliée d'une autre époque.
Depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine, l'abri a rriris
du service. Quand les sirènes
d'alarme retentissent,
les résidents du quartier,
dans la ville de Kryvyï Rih,
y sont invités jusqu'au signal
de la fin du danger.
Les autorités de la ville
tentent de rendre l'endroit
plus accueillant. On y m même
construit une scène pour y faire
des concerts et projeter
des matchs de soccer.
"Dans tous les cas, s'il y avait
une frappe nuclérere, dit-il,
que Dieu nous en préserve, nous
pouvons y rester si longtemps.
Nous avons aussi fait des stocks
de médicaments appropriés pour
les hatatants de la ville,
au cas."
Dans les faits, il est peu
probable que tous ces efforts
ne suffisent à sauver bien des
vies en cas d'attaque à l'arme
nucléaire par la Russie.
Depuis l'invasion russe
de l'Ukraine en février dernier,
la menace d'un recours à l'arme
nucléaire n'est jamais bien loin
dans le discours de Vladimir
Poutine. D'allusions plus ou
moins claires, on est passé
à des menaces à peine voilées
depuis l'explosion survenue
sur le pont de Crimée.
C'est une volée de missiles
traditionnels qui s'abat sur
les villes et la population de
l'Ukraine, mais la possibilité
d'une frappe nucléaire est de
nouveau sur toutes les lèvres.
Sur les plateaux de télévision
russe, la propagande et
les discours les plus extrêmes
se déversent de façon
complètement décomplexée.
"Avec tout ce qui se passe sur
notre territoire, on ne peut pas
écarter une telle décision de
Poutine. Mais je suis certain
que ce serait en dernier
recours, dit-il. La réaction
du monde devrait être immédiate
en cas d'attaque nucléaire.
Poutine doit subir une défaite
cucuisante sans délai."
Alexeï Danilov passe beaucoup
de temps à chercher à comprendre
ce qui se trame dans la tête
du dirigeanteant de la Russie.
Vladimir Poutine a accusé les
forces spéciales ukrainiennes
d'avoir orchestré l'explosion
du pont qui lui était si cher.
Aujourd'hui, la Russie a arrêté
huit personnes en lien avec
ce que le président a qualifié
d'acte terroriste.
Le barrage de missile qui fond
depuis lundi sur l'Ukraine,
c'est sa revanche, a-t-il dit.
Le secrétaire général national
de sécurité et de défense de
l'Ukraine est un de ceux qui
s'étaient réjouis de cette
explosion. Mais aujourd'hui,
il se retient tout juste
d'accuser la Russie d'avoir
fait son propre sabotage.
Une excuse pour frapper
sur des civils, dit-il.
"Nos services de renseignement
nous ont prévenu qu'une teee
attaque allait se produire
dès le 2 ou 3 octobre.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec
ce qu'ils appellent  p pont,
dit-il. C'est une tactique
de la Fédération russe quand les
choses commencent à chauffer.
Il créé d'immens p problèmes
pour la population. C'est un
pays terroriste. Ses dirigeants
sont des criminels de guerre.
Ils peuvent penser à'i'importe
quoi. La vie humaine n'a aucune
valeur pour eux."
Dans les rues de Kryvyï Rih,
on s'accroche à cette vie que
l'on veut plus que tout calme,
banale. On se garde bien
de céder à la panique,
mais certains se préparent.
Arthur croit que ce n'esququ'un
chantage de la part de Vladimir
Poutine. Il n'en est pas moins
sur ses gardes.
"Toute ma famille sait quoi
faire, dit-il. Nous connaissons
les protocoles d'action.
Personnellement, j'ai un abri,
de la nourriture propre, de
l'eau potable. Tout est scellé.
J'ai aussi des respirateurs."Lar
qu'au temps ou Russes et
Ukrainiens se croyait frères.
"Il faut être suicidaire pour
avoir recours au nucléaire,
dit-elle. Les Russes vont
mourir, nous allons mourir et
puis nous détruirons la planète.
Qui voudrait de ça?"
Et la menace nucléaire ne vient
pas que des armes tactiques.
Encore aujourd'hui, la centrale
nucléaire de Zaporijia a été
privée d'électcicité après
une frappe de missiles,
ses réacteurs alimentés
par des groupes générateurs.
Une situation qui ne peut être
que temporaire. Au pays de
la catastrophe de Tchernobyl,
on comprend bien le jeu
dangereux qui se joue.
I M Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Kiev.